et on en parle tout de suite avec un
petit air emmanuelle guigues au maître
de conférences en histoire à
l'université paris est créteil hauteur
de qom et politique les liaisons
dangereuses
monsieur guillaume merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors on vient de le
voir il ya eu le premier conseil des
ministres qui a déjà entériné les
premières mesures qui avaient été prises
par le gouvernement et emmanuel macron
l'a bien précisé
les ordonnances se borneront seulement à
la gestion de la crise mais comment
va-t-il faire puisque cette crise semble
touché a malheureusement tous les
secteurs oui en effet ça va être un vrai
problème je pense que ce qu'il veut dire
par là ils ont envoyé le signal
quand même clair qu'on n'entre pas dans
une période est bien de de semis
dictature en tout cas de sortie
temporaire de la démocratie donc il faut
bien montrer que le gouvernement va
gouverner par ordonnance mais uniquement
et bien ce qui concerne cette gestion de
crise parce que on entendait déjà
certains dans l'opposition dire oui mais
finalement ils vont en profiter pour
faire passer tout un tas de mesures
qu'il souhaitait faire passer depuis
longtemps là on voit que là dessus le
gouvernement essaie d'envoyer des signal
en disant eh bien que c'est plutôt le
contraire d'ailleurs
et bien la réforme des l'assurance
chômage a été repoussée de même pour la
réforme des retraites
donc l'idée c'est de montrer qu'on reste
dans un régime démocratique qui est une
situation d'urgence et comprend tous les
moyens en oeuvre pour traiter cette
situation d'urgence mais que pour le
reste de la politique
eh bien on continuera à rester dans les
formes classiques du gouvernement alors
état d'urgence sanitaire porte des
élections en tout cas du second tour le
projet de loi d'urgence contre le
coronavirus est ce que monsieur guy dos
vous savez à l'heure actuelle ce que
contient ce projet de loi non moi je
suis évidemment malheureusement pas dans
le secret des dieux
donc je peux pas vous en dire plus
malheureusement là dessus alors état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est ce que propose
aussi ce projet de loi en tout cas c'est
actuellement à l'étude
qu'est ce que concrètement ça veut dire
et qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour les
français comparé par exemple à d'état
d'urgence
je pense que ça va être surtout
une gestion tourné vers la santé donc on
a commencé déjà à voir quelques mesures
notamment les restrictions à l'égard des
masques les gels hydro-alcooliques
on le voit également là avec les boîtes
donc de paracétamol qui sont désormais
enfin chaque personne n'a le droit qu'à
une seule boîte
sauf en cas de fièvre donc ça va être
toute une série de mesures qui vont être
prises justement pour éviter
et bien qu'il n'y ait pas les moyens
pour faire face à la situation
et puis aussi une mobilisation une
mobilisation de l'intégralité du
personnel médical y compris le personnel
médical qui est à la retraite ou qui est
en formation qui n'étaient pas
immédiatement disponibles
alors il ya cette polémique c'est vrai
que certains français ont du mal à
comprendre
samedi dernier le gouvernement nous a
appelés à rester chez nous à sortir
uniquement pour des raisons vitales et
dans le même temps ils maintenaient le
premier tour des élections municipales
est-ce que selon vous il ya eu un manque
d'anticipation de la part de l'exécutif
français
oui un petit cafouillage effectivement
sur ddd injonctions contradictoires d'un
côté effectivement rester chez soi et de
l'autre côté la nécessité d'aller voter
donc là effectivement il ya eu quelque
chose de contradictoire
après je trouve quand même problématique
certaines personnes comme agnès buzyn
notamment qui font des révélations
fracassantes mais qui rajoute du coup de
la panique à la crise alors même que le
moment a besoin de solidarité nationale
qu'on a besoin justement d'une plus
grande confiance sans les personnalités
politiques
c'est vrai que la confiance ça se mérite
mais il ya on a quand même besoin bien
une certaine solidarité et les
institutions sont telles qu'elles sont à
l'heure actuelle et la vie démocratique
doit se poursuivre en dépit de cette
solidarité qui doit se faire vouloir
ajouter et bien de la crise à la crise
ça pouvait très largement attendre et
bien quelques mois pour véritablement
sortir
quant à savoir s'il fallait voter ou pas
et bien maintenant on va dire que c'est
un peu trop tard pour y réfléchir
les décisions ont été faites pour le
second tour et maintenant il faut
prendre toutes les mesures d'urgence
ce nécessaire il faut une véritable
solidarité nationale pour faire face à
la crise c'est puis par la suite y aura
un temps pour évidemment et bien juger
les éventuelles responsabilités
bien évidemment vous l'avez dire ce qui
est passé est passé
mais plus généralement comment avez vous
jugé comme avez vous apprécié la gestion
de la crise sanitaire liée au corona
virus par le gouvernement français mais
outre ces malheureux cafouillage et
c'est ces directives contradictoires
on a en tout cas depuis lundi soir une
ligne qui apparaît quand même plus clair
qui a été celle et bien mis en oeuvre
par le chef de l'état qui joue son rôle
de chef de l'état comme l'ont fait ses
prédécesseurs dans des situations de
crise alors qu'ils étaient différentes
pour ses deux prédécesseurs s'étaient
les attentats on a eu des situations de
guerre évidemment notamment durant la
guerre d'algérie et encore avant donc on
le voit assumer cette posture
d'unificateur de la nation de garant de
l'unité nationale qui essaye aussi de
faire passer des messages d'espoir on
voit d'à côté et bien un double rôle
edouard philippe et christophe castaner
qui joue le rôle de la sanction c'est à
dire il faut que vous conformer aux
règles sinon il y aura des sanctions
et puis le chef de l'état qui lui tient
un discours beaucoup plus positif plus
ouvert même certains l'ont accusé de ne
pas avoir parlé de confinement et donc
ne pas avoir les c était assez dur mais
il essaye justement est bien d'être le
le visage de l'unité alors que de
l'autre côté le gouvernement lui il se
veut le garant de l'état de l'ordre car
emmanuel guillot merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
maître de conférences en histoire à
l'université paris est créteil et auteur
de qom et politique
les liaisons dangereuses merci